for as long as humans have walked on
this earth we have stared into the black
expanse of space wondering where our
place in universe was and why we are
here the rhythm of the moon's phases has
guided humanity for millennia but
Galileo was the first to point a
telescope towards it and identify its
mountains and craters not just that he
saw that those distant heavenly bodies
had moons of their own a discovery that
shocked the religious worldview of our
place in the universe fast forward three
hundred years when we've landed twelve
men on our moon an achievement that was
largely driven forward in a world living
in the shadow of a threat of global
nuclear war since that wrath has
subsided our raised to expand into space
has waned the merry Society put it best
with their founding statement
civilizations like people thrive and
challenge and decay without it the time
has passed for human societies to use
war as a driving stress for a
technological progress as the world
moves towards unity we must join
together not a mutual passivity but in
common enterprise facing outward to
embrace a greater and nobler challenge
than that which we previously posed to
each other
pioneering Mars will provide such a
challenge one man has embraced that
challenge like no other and his name is
Elon Musk today we're going to
investigate how will SpaceX get us to
Mars Elon Musk's ultimate goal is to
reduce the cost of space travel he
believes that he can get the cost of a
ticket to Mars down to around half a
million USD the overlap of people who
actually want to go to Mars and the
people who can actually afford it will
be great enough to form the Mars colony
the most efficient way that is the one
that uses the least amount of fuel to
get to Mars from Earth is with the home
and transfer method named after Walter
Holman who first proposed the idea in
1925 with this method you wait for earth
to be at its closest point to the Sun
and then launch Mars needs to be about
forty four point four degrees ahead of
Earth so that Mars will be at its most
distant point from the Sun when the
vehicle arrives this alignment happens
once every 26 months this is not the
shortest or the fastest path to Mars but
requires the least amount of energy
input when getting the cost of travel
down this is the deciding factor
as I mentioned in my last video the
space shuttle could transfer one kilo to
low-earth orbit for about $18,000 the
Falcon 9 can do the same for just 2,700
and SpaceX is continuously working to
reduce that cost let's take a look the
Falcon nines launch sequence and learn
some of the ways SpaceX has reduced the
cost of operation the Falcon 9 first
stage is powered by nine Merlin engines
these engines have the highest thrust to
weight ratio of an e booster engine ever
made at 155 to one this means the
engines can lift more with less fuel and
dude faster at launch the nine engines
produced 7900 kilonewtons of thrust
lifting the 550 tonne rocket off the
ground and gradually accelerating it to
five times the speed of sound this
section called inter stage houses
another Merlin engine that is designed
to work optimally in the vacuum of space
the first stage now separates about 75
kilometers above our planet's surface
and reveals the second stage engine it's
interesting to note that interstage
remains connected to the first stage
after separation this was not the case
for the Saturn 5 as interstage needed to
wait for the engines of the second stage
the fire before separating using
pyrotechnic charges dis ensured a clean
separation as there were worries that
the inter stage would collide with the
engines as it separated due to clearance
issues this is not a problem with the
Falcon 9 making the interstage reusable
and again saving money the merlin engine
of the second stage is designed to be
shut down and restarted multiple times
to deliver the payload to the
appropriate orbit or increase the
velocity enough to perform the Hohmann
transfer to mars the payload is stored
inside this composite fairing which is
big enough to fit a school bus when the
time is ripe the fairing splits in half
and drifts away from the second stage
the payload is now released into orbit
around Earth meanwhile the first stage
is begun its descent back down to earth
coal gas thrusters fired flip it around
once this maneuver is complete the
engines will fire again to bring the
speed down free entry and give an
appropriate trajectory to reach the
landing site upon reentry the grid fins
deploy which provide aerodynamic control
allowing it to steer these are fantastic
little devices that provide excellent
control at supersonic speeds this mesh
structure provides a huge amount of
control surface area in a small amount
of space which allows them to be
he stowed away during launch to reduce
drag grid fins are also much shorter
than conventional planar fins so they
generate less hinge moments meaning they
need smaller motors to control them in
high-speed flow as the first stage
descends closer to sea level the cold
thrusters grid fins and Merlin engines
work together to control the precise
landing on the drone ship barge the
reason SpaceX uses this barrage is
another cost-saving measure the Falcon 9
launches from lon towards Z for safety
reasons when the first stage separates
is over open ocean and if it needed to
return to land it would need to slow
down turn around and use more fuel to
get back to where it started instead the
drone ship can place itself at the
predicted landing zone and wait for the
first stage this way the Falcon 9 just
needs a little bit of extra fuel to slow
itself down to land most people see
SpaceX's true innovation in the reusable
rocket but their innovation in the
manufacturing field is just a
significant SpaceX was the first space
company to employ a method called
vertical integration to manufacture
their Achatz this means that SpaceX
designs and manufactures nearly all of
its components itself the Merlin engines
the aluminium lithium fuel tanks the
compsat fairing for holding the payloads
the Dragon spacecraft the flight
computers and the coding that goes into
them they are all designed and
manufactured by SpaceX comparing this to
the space shuttle Rockwell developed the
orbiter Lockheed Martin developed
external tank and ATK developed the
solid rocket boosters each of these
companies have their own subcontractors
- this adds a huge amount of cost on to
the final price tag each subcontractor
adds a Marco percentage to their selling
price in order to make their own profit
manufacturing everything yourself
eliminates all of these price markups it
cuts out the middleman
like buying popcorn as kernels and
clocking them yourself rather than
buying them from cinema for $10 but has
the added benefit of allowing you to
have full control of your quality
control and create an efficient product
development system all of your employees
can speak and collaborate to improve and
develop new designs Elon insists on open
plan offices to remove any communication
barriers he himself works in a cubicle
this creates the perfect environment for
continual innovation and if we want to
get to Mars that is going to have to
have
so you may be wondering what's next for
SpaceX they will be launching their
Falcon 9 heavy variant at the end of the
year according to SpaceX the Falcon 9
can currently launch one kilo to Mars
for fifteen thousand four hundred
dollars but the heavy variant can launch
one kilo for about six thousand six
hundred the average American weighs 80
kg ignoring all other costs like how you
live on Mars or how you'll survive the
journey there the raw price for a
one-way trip to Mars will be about a
half million dollars musk aims to bring
the price for a roundtrip including all
other expenses to Mars down to half a
million total in 2010
SpaceX presented concept designs for
future heavy lift rockets that will help
towards that goal they're also planning
to replace the nine Merlin engines of
the Falcon 9 with one incredibly
powerful engine dubbed the Merlin 2 that
will increase the thrust to weight ratio
even more I for one I'm really excited
to see what Elon Musk and his incredible
employees have in store for us thanks
for watching as some of you may know I
quit my job earlier this year with the
radicchio ambitious goal of growing this
channel so that I can spread the
incredible work that engineers do all
over the world I never thought I'd be
able to do it full-time for long as I've
been eating away at my savings but
thanks to this week's sponsor I can keep
doing it for a little while longer
so thank you to the grey courses plus
for helping real engineering exist if
you enjoy my videos you'll definitely
like the grey courses plus they have
over 7,000 different lectures from
world-renowned educators there's a huge
range of topics with loads and
Engineering and Technology or you can
learn about photography chess and
cooking you can learn at your own pace
without tests or exams my personal
favorite course so far is the science of
information which teaches the science
and history of how information
technology has transformed our world you
can check that out with a free month
trial by going to the gray courses plus
com ford slash real engineering once
again thanks for watching if you'd like
to see more or support real engineering
the links from my patreon Instagram
Facebook and Twitter accounts are below